what's up guys so as you guys may
already know to demand put on graphics
cars by minors is dropping due to the
consistently dropping price of vert
cryptocurrencies and the consistently
increasing difficulty to mine
cryptocurrency such as atrium as a
result we may see a price drop coming in
the imminent future so should you take
advantage of this price drop and snatch
the GPU when you think it's being
offered for a reasonable price well in
my opinion I think you should wait a
little bit more even if graphics cards
return to MSRP next month because there
are a few new upcoming graphics card
series from Nvidia called cheering and
ampere at first these graphics cars were
expected to be revealed in march and
released in April this may not protrude
and it may take - all the way till
summer for these new graphics cards to
come out but I still think that it is
more wise to wait for these new cards to
come out before buying a graphics card
the next series is just going to be a
Pascal refresh but it should bring with
it noticeable performance upgrades and
GDD are six memory as well there are no
leak specs or anything but if we assume
that in video we'll give a similar
generational gap as the last transition
then the upgrade should be quite nice
for example the 1060 was comparable to
the 980 so this generation the 2060
should be comparable with the 1080 this
would give much superior performance for
the same price and as a result I
definitely think one should wait to see
what Nvidia is bringing out with the
next generation before making decisions
also graphics cars won't return to MSRP
anyways because even if the demand is
taken out of the equation there's still
the problem of overpriced RAM to deal
with so private probably won't return to
MSRP on to the end of this year or until
next year so you weren't really missing
out a great opportunity while waiting a
few more months I know some of you guys
are like but I don't care if there's a
new generation well you should because
the 10 series will drop in price but
still I don't there are some that don't
care too much about a little bit of
money
so should you buy it oh here's what I
think if you're a truly satisfied with
the performance you will get with the 10
series GPU and don't care about the
little bit of money that you would save
then yes you just go ahead and buy 10
series GPU once you think it's
reasonable for you but if you're
thinking man a 1060 would be great but
2060 would be better but I don't know if
it's worth waiting for
well if that's what you're thinking then
please just wait it definitely is worth
the extra performance finally if you're
a more budget oriented then you should
definitely wait because then you could
save money or even afford a better GPU
for the same price but that's pretty
much it guys overall you should wait
before buying a GPU despite prices
dropping great there's a few new series
coming out from Nvidia very soon which
will give you much more performance or
save you some money so it's a really a
win-win situation
plus you've been patient for this long
so you might as well make the wait worth
it instead of getting a GPU that you
could have gotten many months ago before
the price increased for a cheaper price
that is about to be outdated soon so
just think about that before you buy
your next GPU also what do you guys
think about this do you think mining is
not close to declining and that this is
just a little bump in the road or are
you excited to be able to possibly get
GPUs at reasonable prices
make sure to comment what you guys are
thinking I read all my comments and I'm
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts but
that's all I have for you guys this time
if you guys liked this video then make
sure drop a like and if you guys loved
and would like to see more videos just
like this one then make sure to
subscribe and hit that Bell notification
if you wanna be notified every time I
post a new video but until next time bye
[Music]